we start today with another chaos
element in fact thrown into the 2024
Republican primary race the mayor of
Miami Francis Suarez a republican
announced this morning that he is
running for president he's challenging
of course Donald Trump the presumptive
front-runner in that 2024 Republican
race but also Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis Suarez if we say that Trump is
a Floridian now which I guess he is you
know he famously changed his residency
to Florida a Suarez becomes the third
current or former Florida elected
official Floridian elected official I
think better said to enter the race and
this is going to be interesting for a
couple of different reasons one is that
Suarez is Hispanic and there is
increasingly a focus on Hispanic voters
the right talking about hispanic voters
as sort of like don't assume that
they're just going to vote for Democrats
which is true
as I talked about before although
Hispanic voters lean left significantly
not quite as much as black Americans and
Jewish Americans but Hispanic Americans
do lean left Cubans and Venezuelans are
often the exam exception to that and we
are talking about Florida so could this
be maybe a path for Suarez to gain some
Traction in the State of Florida
specifically that's number one number
two there is uh I think a good argument
to be made that Suarez is more of a
moderate he has some corruption issues
but on a number of different policy
areas he's a little more of a moderate
sort of like a technocrat has expressed
support for cryptocurrencies and the
like so I'm as curious as anybody else
to see if and how this impacts the race
let's listen to him this morning on Good
Morning America
oh no the clip glitching badly I'm
confident I'm gonna get it fixed for us
though let's take a listen here Good
morning George it's wonderful to be with
you and Good Morning America why are you
running for president
I'm running for president because I
think I have a different message than
what other candidates have I'm
generational and that generational is a
buzzword but as someone who has
implemented generational change to
create prosperity in the city I'm
someone who was a president of the U.S
Conference of Mayor so I know the
problem that 85 percent of Americans who
live in cities and 91 percent who
constitute the GDP of this country are
going through so this is sounding very
focused groupy and not like it I mean
this is not going to appeal to anyone
things like increasing crime
homelessness mental health issues I'm
someone who has a positive track record
of success and has a positive vision for
the future I think what I've noticed in
the last 24 hours just an outpouring of
support because people want someone who
can unify them I was elected by 85
percent and re-elected by 80 and as I've
traveled the United States from States
like Iowa New Hampshire South Carolina
Nevada what people want is someone to
bring them together they want to know
more they want to hear hear more about
my track record about what I've
accomplished and what I could do for
them and their children this isn't about
me this isn't about my generation this
is about our okay so we'll see if that
message does appeal to anybody the Miami
Herald with an interesting report and
some notes about Suarez which we'll put
up on the screen right now for you
um it says that his brand was recently
tarnished sources told the herald that
Suarez faces scrutiny by the FBI and
local authorities for ten thousand
dollar a month payments he received from
a developer for Consulting work while
serving as mayor which is
extraordinarily Shady that small
potatoes compared to Trump's legal
problems they write but those fees look
like a conflict of interest much as
mounting a long shot yet buzzfilled run
for president in 2020 landed Democrat
Buddha judge a job as U.S Secretary of
Transportation Suarez II might wind up
with a plum political appointment out of
this contest or running another Office
later in other words he could win
without actually winning and lastly
going on to say if he raises enough
money
and gets a couple of viral sound bites
at a presidential debate Suarez might
line up his next job perhaps as
someone's VP or as a paid political
commentator or top political consultant
he's energetic Hispanic fluent in
Spanish appealing to the type of Voters
the Republican party has invested
significant resources to attract as
mayor he's been criticized for focusing
too much on shiny bobbles and less on
the unglamorous job of leading
Miami-Dade County's largest city but
those qualities might play well in
another role so the Miami Herald which
is has followed Suarez very closely says
this is not not only is there no chance
this is not even really about running
for president this is about lining
himself up for some future role VP who
on Earth knows what will be interesting
to see
is whether Suarez can make it to the
debate stage the RNC just uh under two
weeks ago released its requirements for
making it to the first debate in late
August and I don't have them right in
front of me but they are something along
the lines of a fundraising requirement I
think it's you have to raise money from
at least 40 000 different people
um and you've got to be polling at least
one percent in I believe three different
National polls Suarez can certainly get
himself to one percent and I'm more
interested in what his presence on the
stage could do as a Florida elected
official in contrast to Ron DeSantis you
may have two voices Trump and Suarez
attacking desantis's record at floor as
Florida Governor that would be
interesting it will also be interesting
to see what attacks DeSantis mounts
against Suarez my guess is Trump will
mostly ignore Suarez if they're on the
stage together
um and instead uh just attacked DeSantis
so that will be an interesting dynamic
in the meantime we are going to get a
republican polling update uh tomorrow
but let's talk about a Chris Christie
appearance on Fox News as I have told
you many times now Chris Christie
certainly before Miami mayor Francis
Suarez announced he was running and
maybe even still Chris Christie is by
far the most reasonable Republican
candidate that is presenting himself for
the Republican nomination if I were
voting in the Republican nomination a
process I would choose Chris Christie
easily Chris Christie has been telling
uncontroversial truths which within the
Maga world are very controversial he
appeared yesterday on Fox News and quite
frankly
it didn't seem like Fox News hosts bill
hemmer and I believe this is Dana Perino
wanted to hear these uncontroversial
truths sprinkling Christy with many of
the same talking points that we've heard
from Maga for a while now take a listen
to this the border is ridiculous and by
the way policies did much better in
everything you just mentioned but wait a
second his post policies did not do
better at the border okay at the border
we had a diminution in what we're seeing
now but remember what he promised in
2016. he was going to build a wall
across the entire Border in his first
four years and Mexico was going to pay
for it well we got a wall that's about a
quarter of the way done and Mexico has
given us one peso yet now Chris Christie
is of course completely correct the idea
that Trump was going to build a wall
across the entire U.S Mexico border as
if that would even stop the the problem
that they're trying to solve but put
that aside for a moment Trump said we're
going to build a wall across the entire
border during my first term Mexico is
going to pay for it Trump didn't do it
and Mexico didn't pay you and I knew in
2016 that that was never going to happen
however
Chris Christie who now acts as if that
was an obviously ridiculous promise
never called Trump out on it in 2016 or
2017 or 2018 or 2019 or 2020. now that
Christy has distance from Trump has
criticized Trump and is running against
him now he points out the absurdity now
Chris Christie is completely correct
he's completely correct but he's only
opportunistically doing this now he knew
all along it was a ridiculous promise
stayed mum for as long as he was
supporting Donald Trump here's another
clip from this Fox news interview of
Chris Christie on a debate stage he's
going to say Biden stopped it and you
can go down to the Border today and see
piles of Steel that are just laying
there in the in the Arizona desert yeah
Bill those piles of Steel have been
sitting there since Donald Trump was
President he didn't get it done he
couldn't convince the Republican
Congress to fund the wall he couldn't
finish it and he didn't change one
immigration law now in this particular
interview
Chris Christie is telling obvious truths
and Fox News host Bill hemmer is
carrying bucket loads of water for Trump
and for Maga the saddest part about all
of this to me is that this proves
something we've long suspected
reasonable Republicans to the extent
that they exist and to the extent that
they exist I would include Chris
Christie on that on that list reasonable
Republicans do actually know that their
normal talking points are lies they know
that including the ones that Chris
Christie himself repeated
when he was behind Trump literally and
figuratively during Donald Trump's first
term or at least the majority of it and
yet he was still willing to tell those
lies I would suggest to you and you tell
me whether you agree or disagree I would
suggest to you
that it's actually more depraved
that they know these talking points are
bogus but they repeat them when they are
on the correct team and then all of a
sudden when it's no longer useful to
them they abandon those talking points
this is the sort of thing
certainly I would never do and I think
there are many elected officials out
there who wouldn't do it we may win or
lose we may get the best or the worst of
a particular election or a debate but I
don't care who's saying it to you if
it's a Democrat or it's a republican if
it's someone I support or if it's
someone I oppose if someone says I'm
going to build a wall in four years and
I'm going to get a different country to
pay for it I'm going to tell you that
that's BS this is the difference morally
and ethically between some that are
operating in the political sphere and
others so on the one hand yes Chris
Christie is telling the truth now after
years of lying Chris Christie is a far
more moderate Republican than many of
these other clowns Chris Christie
actually has some critical thinking and
intelligence abilities that would make
him a far better president than people
like Trump or DeSantis or others all of
those things are true it is also true at
the same time and this is living with
the conflict of what it is to be a
person in the world at the same time
despite all of those positive traits I
just outlined about Chris Christie he's
a guy who with no hesitation that
unflinchingly didn't even flinch didn't
even glitch for years repeated or at
least stood aside as others were telling
these obvious lies in service to being
close to power and to being friendly
with the president and all of the
reasons that would encourage Chris
Christie to do what he did for four
years so if if you said David you're
voting in the Republican primary this
year who do you pick I pick Chris
Christie does that mean I think this guy
is the epitome and holy grail of
morality and ethics and politics no I do
not he was as dishonest as the rest of
them for many many years let's take a
very quick break it's actually shocking
how packed today's program is which is
why I'm wasting 30 seconds right now
telling you how packed today's program
is
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com join pacman.com
I haven't had time to mention it this
week but our program is funded primarily
by our viewers through something called
the membership program we're not like
the daily wire or Fox News where we have
ultra wealthy people dropping massive
dumps of dollars on us and saying do
whatever the hell you want no we
actually depend on and are accountable
to our audience and I would love for you
to join the ranks of membership at
joinpakman.com it's really quick it's
cheap it's easy we do an extra show
every day for our members and I want to
give a special welcome to all of the new
members from this week and by the way
just all the new audience members this
has been one of the biggest weeks for
the show uh certainly in months if not
of the entire year and I really
appreciate everybody you can sign up at
joinpakman.com using the coupon code
indicted again all right we're gonna do
a deep dive now into what is happening
psychologically
epistemologically and cognitively with
your average Trump voter right now now
let me set this up for you we're going
to look at a couple of focus groups
groups Foci we might even call them okay
that PBS did with voters
and if I came to you and I said folks
um I'm gonna pull back the curtain and
show you the insanity of the voters who
want a flat tax you would probably look
at me and say David that's not super
interesting like wanting a flat tax even
if I disagree with it it's not really
indicative of something wacky and zany
that's going on and I would agree with
you but we have a situation right now
where we have a twice indicted twice
impeached globally humiliated failed
former president with significant
evidence of criminality against him
innocent until proven guilty of course
running a campaign that is absolute
lunacy and yet there are still
presumably tens of millions of people
that support the guy we're gonna try to
figure out what's going on that's the
introduction let's jump into the video
and then we'll discuss how many of you
know that Donald Trump was indicted last
week
everybody raises their hands although
some sort of reluctantly how many of you
have heard that Donald Trump wasn't for
a second time recently
and the reason for hearing the questions
twice is there's two focus groups here
and they're switching between the two
everybody knows okay from the 16
Republican voters we gathered yesterday
evening there were strong reactions to
the second indictment of former
president Donald Trump well I think he's
being set up oh yeah tell me why well
um it's just too
arranged everything is just too arranged
and when the FBI went in and raided his
property at Mar-A-Lago how do we know
what they did and what they didn't do
right and wrong are just totally messed
up we had asked pollster Sarah Longwell
who also publishes the center right
website the bulwark to assemble two
panels of GOP voters in the studio of
Iowa PBS I observed from the control
room she asked how they're thinking
about politics policy and current events
at this moment the candidates are
already descending upon their state
ahead of next year's caucuses and as the
news of the second Trump indictment had
been breaking it's baloney I think I
think uh I mean just why isn't Biden
indicted just because he gave them back
at an appropriate time I mean really so
he did exactly the same thing well you
have a current president who is sifting
all of the doj on a potential candidate
that's never happened right right yeah
they really feel like the country's
going in the wrong direction afterwards
Longwell who has conducted hundreds okay
so let's pause there
so asked their thought they all had
heard of the indictment asked about
their thoughts on the indictment they
said it's clearly a setup
the photos appear to have been staged
sort of like we don't know what the FBI
did meaning they staged or set it up in
some way it's baloney Biden did the same
thing and should be arrested or charged
himself Biden sicked the doj on Trump
for which there is quite literally no
evidence whatsoever no evidence
whatsoever let's continue support for
Donald Trump how many of you distrust
the FBI
the three-letter agencies the doj the
CIA the FBI I think when the company of
the country was formulated the best of
intent was to put some of these um
organizations or governing bodies in
place but how they're being manipulated
now and they're being weaponized is the
baker concern this is just straight up
what what Maga has been feeding these
folks these folks have uncritically
accepted these bogus talking points I'm
kind of frustrated by that because on
one side you know it seems like we're
all going all out on President Trump and
on the other side
the wheels of Justice are going very
slow it doesn't seem to be like equal
amount of resources being devoted to
looking into Hunter Biden's laptop and
100 but so Hunter Biden's laptop is is
an issue for these folks in thinking
about what's going on right now in the
Republican Party about Hillary Clinton
that's all this stuff and she was never
indicted you've got the doj you've got
the FBI reporting up to Biden ultimately
this goes up to Biden so why wouldn't
you want to take out your your toughest
political opponent and this is election
interference like we've never seen
before that is a trump quote I mean
that's that's just that's what Trump
posts to truth Central this is election
interference like we've never seen
before that's where they get this stuff
and it's disguised as Trump's a bad guy
how many of you wanted Hillary Clinton
to be indicted for her uh okay did you
think okay so of the people at the table
uh two of the eight did not raise their
hand that they wanted Hillary indicted
you should go to jail yes for what she
did absolutely because Trump now that's
interesting
they're saying Hillary should have gone
to jail
Hillary was these are the folks who
claim to be about Law and Order and
bemoan lack of due process when it comes
to Trump they're saying Hillary should
have gone to jail they don't know about
the evidence
they seem not to care that Hillary was
cleared they seem not to know that there
was no chargeable crime that Hillary was
involved in but while staying out of one
side of their mouth we're for Law and
Order and due process and the justice
system working properly they're saying
imprison Hillary Clinton despite the
fact that she was cleared of criminality
I'm uh said that she should go to jail
for mishandling classified information
do you think he should be held to the
same standard that he was setting for
Hillary Clinton or do you think that
it's different for some reason I think
he said that when you understand his
personality and how he
um how he words thinks he said that
ingest so there you that's this that's a
great moment okay this is what we call
cognitive dissonance or magical thinking
depending on your perspective
they're asked you know Trump said
Hillary should also be locked up for
those things but now Trump did it what
about we simply hold Trump to the
standard he said should be applied to
Hillary Clinton and they go well when
Trump said Hillary should be locked up
he was kidding but these folks just said
Hillary should be locked up were they
also kidding 30 seconds earlier it
doesn't matter they're in a world of
their own he didn't I think he's just
trying to paint a word picture but
should she have gotten some sort of uh
punishment yes yes I think so he's
entitled to declassify whatever he wants
to declassify so in other presidents
that have left office have had
classified documents again another
talking point straight from the right
Trump is entitled to declassify things
Trump admits in audio recordings he
didn't declassify those things the
actions for which Trump has been
indicted took place after he was
president when we talk about Obama or
bush and their documents they arranged
with Nara to temporarily store documents
in specific places disclosing where that
was on a temporary basis until they
could be permanently located either at
presidential libraries or other places
it's not true what this guy is saying
but it is in lockstep with what Trump
and Mark Levin and these other
right-wing figures have fed to them they
were not treated the same way as Donald
Trump is being treated it is a two-tier
justice system in this country literally
another word another phrase from Trump
this is what this guy has fallen for all
of it for sure there's no doubt about it
the biggest thing is that all right
let's skip ahead a little bit here to
other moments uh from from the panels if
you're interested in the interview
between Judy Woodruff and um uh the the
pollster Sarah Longwell you can you can
check this out it was showing the
Capitol Police walking these people
through the capitol talking
no problems whatsoever this is another
right-wing argument which they have been
fed and have uncritically accepted if
what the rioters did was so wrong why
did the Capitol Police welcome them and
of course once you realize well what was
going on was once police realized
they've been unable they are unable to
uh keep a crowd back then you have to
give way and at that point what you want
to do is keep people calm but the idea
was the Capitol Police thought it was
great they just welcomed the protesters
how can you charge them and then they
turn around and say
they they attacked us right in essence
the videos show a whole different story
than what they're saying happened
arguably once we got the videos from the
January 6 committee what happened is
even worse than what was originally
reported but this guy wants to say it
really wasn't a big deal I personally
don't think that like he was calling
people to like do like I watched like
what he said and everything and like I
mean he didn't say anything to me like
in watching it that was like you know oh
yeah he's telling them to go and like
storm the capital you know like I didn't
feel I personally didn't feel like that
um that what he was said was so
inflammatory that he was just trying to
like you know tear the country apart
they're still arresting people too he
quite literally was trying to overturn
the results of an election he lost if
that's not an action to tear a country
apart I don't know what is two years
right since it happened he loves his
country I can't believe this right Riley
loves this country
because right people to fight like that
and he's against Wars this is not the
typical politician and uh his words
aren't what we call polished and he has
blurted out do people want to vote for a
republican candidate who is committed to
pardoning the people from January 6th
yes absolutely yeah that's interesting
they want that they actively want a
candidate who will pardon who will
pardon the rioters they are so convinced
of the Innocence of those individuals
guilty of these charges he goes through
the courts and they find him guilty to
raise your hand if it makes you support
him more
okay the question is if Trump is found
guilty do you support him more remember
due process we're now not talking about
the justice department we're talking
about a jury we're talking about a jury
just like this group of people as scary
as that is finding Trump guilty one two
three four five six of the eight people
say I would support Trump more if he
were found guilty by a jury of his peers
raise your hand if it makes you support
him less
no one
and president Trump retains some measure
of support even among those who think he
likely committed a crime I read the
indictment
um and it's plain as day that he broke
the law knowingly whether the doj
um came after him
uh which I think is very plausible and
why they're ignoring Hunter Biden's
laptop I think is a separate issue
but it is clear he broke the wall and I
think it's time for him to go away
and uh
I I appreciated what he did for the
country
during his four years but I think that
he is part of the problem but when asked
if he'd vote for Trump if he were the
nominee running against President Biden
Trump's the nominee versus Biden what
will you do I would vote for him for the
third time you would
I think that uh it's that significant so
given that and the fact that they're
potential I think you get the picture we
are dealing here this is why at the top
of this segment I said if I told you
guys I've got a group of people that
wants a flat tax check out how insane
this is we would all say that's a very
specific policy disagreement that
doesn't raise the source of moral and
ethical cult type questions that these
focus groups raise what this means for
the Democratic party and the left from a
strategy perspective there's a whole
bunch of stuff culturally
sociologically
anthropologically that is going to take
decades to unwind from this sort of
cultishness I'm not dealing with that
right now what this means from a
political strategy standpoint as I've
said before is that it is not worth the
time to try to convince these folks of
anything
the right way to invest time and
resources for Democrats that want to win
is to work on just getting the vote out
from those who would otherwise stay home
that are as horrified by this stuff as
we are in a country with a 50 to 60
percent turnout rate you don't need to
convince those people you just need to
find folks and say you're not voting
well then one of these people in the
focus group is going to have a say in
how the country is run instead of you
and if that doesn't motivate more people
to vote quite frankly I don't know what
would make sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel our uh we had a forensic
audit done of the YouTube channel last
month we looked for bamboo fibers
barbecue sauce all sorts of stuff all
over YouTube subscriptions what we found
was that last month more than three
million people watched our videos and
did not subscribe if just 10 percent of
those folks were to subscribe we would
get to our 2 million subscriber goal
overnight help us get there hit that
subscribe button we'll take a quick
quick break and be back with so much
more
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Eric
Levitz who writes about politics and
economics for New York Magazine and
wrote a very interesting piece blaming
capitalism is not an alternative to
solving problems Eric great to have you
on I really appreciate your time
yeah thanks for having me I thought the
piece was interesting because it's not
really a defense of capitalism but it's
a pragmatic approach to sort of I would
say the realities of the American
economy
um groups within that economy political
orientation and some of the issues that
that are sort of facing us can you talk
a little bit just big picture about the
connection between the economic ideas of
Voters versus how they evaluate the
economic ideas as presented by elected
officials for example if a
self-described free market capitalist
hears about the green New Deal how or
with what rubric what standards voters
tend to apply when they evaluate the
economic proposals of candidates in this
sort of context that you write about
sure I mean I think that
um one thing to say is that
ordinary voters uh you know who are much
less politically engaged I think than
the type of people that would watch this
YouTube show or that read my articles
you know they have a lot of
contradictory intuitions about the
economy which you can often see in
certain polls where just small changes
in wording can really yield really
different results so right uh posts
consistently find that if you ask people
is the government spending too much on
welfare that a majority of people will
say yes there's government spending too
much on welfare if you ask is the
government spending too much or should
the government spend more on the poor
you get a large majority of Americans
saying yes the government should spend
more on the poor
um and so there's you know really sort
of different conflicting moral
intuitions that people have people
voters tend to believe that there is um
you know a fundamental sort of right to
that the federal government has a
responsibility to ensure that everybody
can afford you know basic Goods like
Health Care they have a sense that you
know people are entitled uh to jobs
people who want to work at the same time
there is a
aversion to the idea that somebody is
going to be getting government help and
not contributing to the economy
there is a sense that um you know a very
heightened sensitivity to
consumer prices and a vague
worries about the idea of the federal
deficit and debt that conservatives can
weaponize and so there's just a lot of
different in Kuwait intuitions that
depending on the narrative that elected
officials provide and the media
amplifies you can get the mass public to
view even the same policies in different
ways and um certainly there is
you know not a tremendous amount of
coherence
with people down the line agreeing with
the conservative ideology on every
question uh nor for that matter the the
progressive one
you talk quite a bit about climate
change and some of that inconsistency
and some of the components within that
including public opinion about policies
like carbon taxes or restricting nuclear
energy or hydropower can you talk a
little bit about the inconsistency of
support in sort of the context of
figuring out which what the public wants
done quote about climate change yeah
sure I mean in the context of the piece
I'm talking about sort of the necessity
of
reform of a fundamentally
doing the sometimes uh Inglorious work
of building coalitions and getting the
most that you can at any given moment
given the balance of forces in the
government and in the economy
versus a sort of revolutionary
vision of how you make change on climate
change which would Envision blowing up
pipelines natural gas pipelines taking
direct action and in my point that I
make is that I think that
I'm skeptical of those strategies
specifically because I think that people
who proselytize for them haven't fully
grappled with the state of Mass opinion
on climate change which is that most
people regard climate change as a
problem they believe the science they
are vaguely worried about it at the same
time
for most you know working class lower
middle class people
the imperatives of making their monthly
budgets work is just it's so much more
Salient and and so much more top of Mind
than the sort of abstract concern of the
long-term ecological problems that our
economy is creating and so if you have a
situation where
the imperative to tackle climate change
is put into direct conflict with making
energy more expensive
um which you know potentially could
happen if you have a bunch of uh
terrorists eco-terrorists
um you know blowing up uh pipelines and
you have a breakdown in the the sort of
natural gas infrastructure of the
country that could result in a
significant increase in people's energy
bills which could build public support
for a government Crackdown an
environmentalists
um you know so so that I think is
something to to think about there and I
think that the virtue of a green New
Deal type strategy is that it attempts
to reconcile the competing imperatives
of
expanding Economic Opportunity in a
sense of felt prosperity in the present
with making sure that our economy is
economically rather ecologically
sustainable in the long term
there are
um even among my even among the
left-wing portion of my audience there
is disagreement about which approach
would achieve the most change the most
quickly longer term uh incrementalism or
like a sort of revolutionary more
accelerationist perspective of break it
all down and rebuild it in the way we
want which I think the blowing up of
pipelines that you suggest would kind of
be in in that latter
um philosophy
unincrementalism you know when you talk
about climate change sometimes you say
to people well you know four percent of
cars now being sold or electric and if
we can get that to eight and then 12 and
then you know by 2035 for a lot of
people that Rings true as the right and
correct way to do it and the way that
actually will get them the change to
happen faster in the long run
others say no no no that's like you're
gonna have to do something much more
radical or drastic than that is there
agreement not agreement is there
consensus on on that like how popular
nationally is The accelerationist View
on some of these issues versus the
incremental
um I'm not sure how
much the question of you know do you
support a ecological revolution has been
pulled but I I would say that generally
speaking you know
if you look at just polling about how
people describe themselves self-identify
ideologically right
um and gallops polling about 75 percent
of the country identifies as either
moderate or conservative
there's a lot of ambiguity about what
people mean when they say that if you
looked at 2020 primary polls you would
often see that um
that that Bernie Sanders was second
among Democrats who identified as
moderate right uh so you know people
mean different things by that but I
think that the ideological identifiers
are meaningful enough that there are
just not a lot of people in that super
majority who identifies either
conservative or moderate who favor
revolutionary violence you know I I
think that that's just not
America for all of its Myriad problems
is is a very
prosperous Society in in relative terms
we have
uh you know the the poor in our country
have a really bad situation in many
respects because of the weaknesses in
our social welfare system but the middle
class uh has a lot to lose and from you
know the idea of displacing the entire
social order and so it's just it's not a
revolutionary Society
um and so that's that that's a
fundamental problem for those who
you know make I think
I think one one valid point in in the
argument from those who favor a more
revolutionary Outlook is that it is true
that the what is on offer through
plausible incremental legislative change
at this moment
um does not like it's going to be
sufficient to keep global temperatures
below 1.5 degrees Celsius
[Music]
um
that could change we could have some
technological breakthrough that really
changes the game but right now it looks
like we're going to go past that point
and then we're going to need to rely on
some degree of removing carbon from the
atmosphere some degree of
geoengineering
um
to to get it back below that and that's
a really hazardous place to be and we
don't know exactly where the Tipping
points that are going to make
kick off feedback cycles that accelerate
the process are they could be well past
1.5 degrees Celsius but they could be
even before that and so it's a dangerous
situation that we're in and I understand
why people are frustrated by the
auctions that are on the table my belief
is just that if you want to create a
politically sustainability
politically sustainable Coalition for
minimizing climate change that that is
going to involve making concessions to
majoritarian opinion which does not
favor
a revolutionary term if we zoom out a
little more and again I'll remind people
that the title of the piece is blaming
capitalism is not an alternative to
solving problems it is very uh popular
among the left to blame capitalism in a
number of different ways for many of the
problems that we're facing even going
Beyond climate change the idea of
capitalism as the superstructure that
has both enabled and even encouraged and
incentivized the sorts of behaviors and
Industry and rent seeking Etc that got
us to where we are and that since
capitalism is the cause it certainly
isn't going to be the solution I think
that would be the view of of some on
this this issue is your argument to the
extent that you're making one that even
if the blame is correct it's not the
right focus in terms of finding
Solutions or do you question whether the
blame is actually correct
it's going to depend on how we specify
our terms and how we Define capitalism
and in what specific uh issues we're
looking at with regard to climate change
I think it's complicated I think that
when
could make the argument that
keeping warming within 1.5 degrees that
a precondition is to significantly more
socialize and plan the economy than
existing American capitalism allows
support
at the same time
the idea maybe that's a necessary
condition but I don't think that's
sufficient because if we look at the
environmental record of the Soviet Union
if we look at the the non-capitalist
economies that have existed
um they have done tremendous carbon
emissions as well in tremendous
environmental damage and uh you know
this um socialist writer Lee Phillips
had a piece a while ago making the
argument that if you know we had had a
global socialist system in the 20th
century that climate change would
actually have been worse because before
the science became clear we would have
been wanting to spread the the fruits of
industrial modernity to everybody on the
planet so instead of just the West
enjoying the you know massive increases
in living standards the fossil fuel
economy uh made possible you know in an
ideal socialist utopian world right the
people in you know sub-Saharan Africa
would have also been enjoying the
benefits in the mid-20s Century of
automobiles and in television
electronics and everything we would have
had more emissions by the time in the
1970s when we got a really clear sense
of the hazards now his argument is that
nonetheless socialism is the cure
because it can allow us to more rapidly
switch out the energy basis of our
society than a capitalist pre-market
system wouldn't allow but is it just a
little bit more complicated than that
because
ultimately climate change is a product
of industrial modernity and that is
we've had communist and capitalist
versions of that and both of them have
created considerable emissions
much of what we've been talking about
today is related to Eric's peace blaming
capitalism is not an alternative to
solving problems we've been speaking
with Eric Levitz who writes about
politics and economics for New York
Magazine Eric really appreciate your
time and insights today yeah thanks for
talking to me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Sarah Palin was asked to explain why
trumpism is not a cult and she explained
why trumpism is a cult this is a really
really stunning video and it confirms
just about everything we've been talking
about for years now Sarah Palin appeared
on Newsmax and she was basically given
one of these softball questions where
it's like Trump people aren't cultists
right and Sarah Palin goes absolutely
not because cultists are and then she
defines it and she is of course
describing trumpists take a listen to
this I was with the Trump motorcade
yesterday and I would say that the
people at Versailles at the Cuban
restaurant I wouldn't call them cult
members would you
uh no you know the definition of a cult
is a group of people who are excessively
supporting one another and a cause all
about Conformity and compliance and
intolerance of anyone who doesn't agree
with what their mission is okay that's
the definition of what the left is
engaged in right now speaking of Colts
all about Conformity and compliance and
heaven forbid you don't agree with them
isn't that the best by just about any
accurate definition
hardcore Maga is indeed a cult they have
beliefs and practices that are strange
or even Sinister including denying the
reality of the world insofar as climate
change covid the 2020 election results
they worship Trump as this Messianic
figure
who can do no wrong must be obeyed at
all costs and many of them even see him
as a pseudo deity they are characterized
by their devotion not only to Trump but
the ideology he espouses which they
often express through symbols including
Maga hats or Flags or banners or signs
and symbols they have a system of
beliefs that are
pseudo-religious and rituals which are
directed towards Trump they pray for him
or they pray over him as we saw at the
Cuban Cafe Versailles in Miami on
Tuesday they attend his rallies and
chant his slogans they storm the capital
on his behalf committing crimes on his
behalf and they have this self-appointed
leader Trump
who claims to be the only one that can
save them that can save America and they
believe it these are all cult traits and
of course Trump for his part of it
excessively controls his followers
through lies fear threats manipulation
requiring them to believe what he says
and to do what he wants donating or
voting or chanting or whatever the case
may be and these are all beliefs that
most of the world considers deviant or
depraved and much of the United States
as well compare this to Biden supporters
okay Biden supporters aren't obsessed
with symbols or rituals Biden supporters
aren't obsessed with Biden in fact most
of us don't even really care about Joe
Biden like what I mean by that is I
don't want harm to come to him but I
don't care about Biden as a figure
I'm not interested in defending Biden if
he did something wrong if he did
something wrong investigate him or
charge him or whatever I'm interested in
policy and I'm interested in ideas and
if Biden is going to be the person to
push those that's great and if it's
somebody else that's fine too we don't
consider Biden the ultimate source of
Truth the way maggots consider Trump to
be I don't consider MSNBC or whatever
Democratic establishment media is out
there to be the ultimate source of Truth
the way they consider whether it's Fox
News or Newsmax or whatever is the
flavor of the month to be an ultimate
source of truth I don't feel any need to
reflexively defend Biden against any
criticism yeah Biden's just not
Progressive enough on some policies yeah
Biden's looking dramatically more frail
than he used to yeah I also don't see
criticisms of Biden
as attacks on the Free World on
Democracy on the media on our country
okay criticize Biden I'll tell you if I
agree or if I disagree it is a dramatic
contrast when you think about what it
means to be in a cult occult member
occult leader and Sarah Palin
hilariously and trying to say no no no
no there's no cult here actually
confirmed there is indeed a cult Mike
Pence is having a tough go of it Mike
Pence appeared uh on a radio program
yesterday
and Mike Pence as you may know has not
committed to pardoning Donald Trump if
Trump were to be indicted on any of
these various indictments that he is
facing and possibly future uh
indictments the host didn't like it and
confronted Mike Pence and it actually is
is quite interesting take a listen to
this ultimate decider with all due
respect when you aren't telling us what
your decision would be I think you're
dodging the question and and and frankly
not stepping up on the on the front of
leadership which in the past you've been
willing to do so I I to me not answering
is a no
well look I
number one I don't think you know what
the president's defense is do you
I mean what are the facts
I mean look we either believe in our
in our tree or we don't we understand
by the rule of law we don't I just
thought what I would tell you is I think
as someone what I'm hearing is you're
fine with Donald Trump being put in
prison sir and that to me since you were
his vice president feels pretty
disrespectful I had a standard rule I
don't talk about hypotheticals look we
don't know what the president's defense
here is I think he's entitled to make
his defense entitled to have his day in
court and uh look let's you know let's
take it one step at a time but I I would
just tell you that I I uh but if you
know that these are political charges
and you do this is not a this is not a
difficult decision I think we've gotten
I think we've gotten what we're going to
get here in terms of an answer to this
one um yeah
I guess the clay and buck show and the
co-host is like yeah we we probably
should move on I think any conclusion by
anyone running for the presidency of the
United States that would prejudge the
facts in this case or prejudge the
investigation into President Biden or
his family his premature sure let's let
let's let the process play out let's
follow the facts and I promise you as
president of the United States I'll do
just that
so you know the bar is extremely low
I I want to say to you this is more or
less the right answer but it's only more
or less the right answer once we've
adjusted our expectations and put the
bar really really low around Mike Pence
and case in point
three weeks ago Pence was singing a
different tune when the indictment was
the one out of New York Pence only
recently changed his tune we we reported
this to you yesterday Mike Pence has
sudden change of heart over Trump
classified documents I can't defend it
having read the indictment these are
very serious allegations Pence told the
Wall Street journal's editorial board
Tuesday so in one sense Pence is correct
why on Earth would I tell you now I'm
going to Pardon someone when they
haven't even put on a defense they
certainly haven't been convicted we just
don't have enough information the
Counterpoint from the hosts is if you
concede the charges are merely political
in nature then does it really matter
what the defense is wouldn't you be
inclined to say that you're going to
Pardon Donald Trump because the bar is
so low it is 2023 I'm not going to
pretend that we're in the 90s okay or
the late 80s or whatever the bar is so
low that I'm will willing to give Pence
some credit for saying to this guy
you're not going to get me to say right
now that I'm going to Pardon Trump the
question that becomes increasingly
interesting is we're seeing a split
among Republican candidates some who say
I would absolutely pardon Trump and
others who say no I wouldn't or at least
I can't commit to that right now that is
becoming a clash between the candidates
and it will be very interesting to see
if that issue comes up in the debates
which will be starting in August let's
talk about the polling update
Chris Christie sit down for this one
okay sit down for this one listen to
this Chris Christie's polling has surged
70 percent since he announced he is
running
think that through okay Chris Christie
has surged 70 in the polls
from one percent
to 1.7 percent
that is an increase of 70 percent now I
genuinely don't know whether that bodes
well for Chris Christie or not okay here
are the numbers as they stand this
morning Donald Trump has seen a bit of a
dip Trump dropping from about 56 to 52
losing Four Points
Rhonda sanctimonious uh dropping from 24
to about 21 or 22. and Chris Christie
who entered uh the race at one percent
has now surged to 1.7 percent so it's
all sort of tongue-in-cheek obviously
1.7 percent is not going to get Chris
Christie what he needs to be the nominee
but it is interesting as far as
percentages goes
uh Chris Christie is the candidate who
has seen by far the largest search you
know those uh thought experiments if I
give you a penny and you double it every
day for a month how much money do you
end up with and people go I don't know
like 20 bucks and it's some insane
number I don't know what it is if Chris
Christie can keep gaining 70 a week
he'll be in really good shape by the
time the debates start of course this
may be the roof this may be what some
call a dead cat bounce in the stock
market it may be Christie announced the
one percent has now grown to almost
double that and that's going to be Chris
Christie's ceiling we simply don't know
we'll dive a little more deeply into
this tomorrow there is also New National
polling a yougov poll has Biden even
with Trump in a national election uh
among registered voters among all adults
Trump is actually ahead there is a
premise poll out a couple of days ago
which has Biden up five over DeSantis
among registered voters and has Biden up
one over Trump among registered voters
and then the best rated poll of all of
these uh in fact the two best rated
polls of all of these are Quinnipiac and
Suffolk University Quinnipiac has Biden
up by four over Trump and Suffolk has
Biden up seven over DeSantis and up two
over Trump the race is starting to take
shape that is more defined and less
blurry we're going to look in
significantly more detail at these polls
tomorrow we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to David P Speaking of
Chris Christie and Joe Biden here's a
caller asking about exactly those two
people
David do you think that Chris Christie
would beat Joe Biden
and my next question would be do you
think Chris Christie
if he did win the nominee
would he start going
anti-anti woke crap too
okay so two questions there if it were
Christy versus Biden does Christy have a
shot second question if Christy became
the nominee would he go anti-woke let's
answer the second one first because it's
simpler the anti-woke stuff is more
useful within the Republican primary
than in the general election why because
most of the country actually agrees with
the quote woke side of most issues so if
Chris Christie doesn't go anti-woke
while running in the primary he is not
going to go anti-woke as a general
election candidate that I am confident
in the first question if the matchup
were Christy versus Biden in November of
2024 could Christy win I believe the
answer is yes I believe that if Maga was
soundly defeated if Trump really
crumbles and what I mean by that is he's
indicted a third time it becomes
absolutely impossible to even be out on
the campaign Trail because he's just
busy with three different criminal
defenses Republicans abandon him imagine
they select Chris Christie I believe
that that this would actually create a
Resurgence among the Republican
electorate where all of these folks who
have been dissuaded from even
participating because they're disgusted
with Trump or they just think Trump is
the wrong direction for the party I
believe all of those folks would get
engaged I believe also that there are
some people who voted for Biden in 2020
because they were so disgusted with
Trump who if there was a reasonable
Republican would actually go back to
voting Republican and so I'm not here to
tell you Christy would definitely beat
Joe Biden but if Trump is running even
with Biden I do believe that Chris
Christie has a solid shot of defeating
Biden in a general election I'm not
hoping for that I'm answering the
caller's question we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today we're going to
talk about the coming heat wave in Texas
are they actually prepared for it this
time we will talk about Cornell West now
after announcing that he's running as a
People's Party candidate also seeking
the green party nomination I'm going to
be honest with you it's all a complete
and total mess and we will give you the
latest not so good news about Tesla's
self-driving system which I have tested
out myself by the way all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com
foreign